say more congressman appreciate your
coming on tonight
so i don't think of you as someone given
to hyperbole you're not throwing wild
charges out there you measure your words
you said you are concerned that we are
moving towards a police state
tell us why you're worried well tucker
the very first thing
that any president does after they've
gotten elected any member of congress
and
and every one of us who has served in
the military is we take an oath
and we swear to support and defend the
constitution of the united states
against all enemies foreign and domestic
the reason that this is the first thing
that we do is because our constitution
is the foundation of this country and
who we are it is what guarantees us our
civil liberties
uh our freedoms that are endowed to us
not by any man
or person in government but are endowed
to us
by our creator and so this is
something that we must all unite around
this is something that we recognize that
those who stormed the capitol on january
trying to stop congress from uh
fulfilling their constitutional
responsibilities they were acting as
domestic terrorists undermining our
constitution
as you pointed out in my video those
like john brennan
adam schiff and others are also acting
as domestic terrorists because they are
also undermining our constitution by
trying to take away
our civil liberties and rights that are
guaranteed
to us if you don't mind i'd like to just
quote john brennan directly
so that people can't say i'm taking this
out of context directly john brennan
says members of the biden team who have
been nominated or appointed
are now moving in laser-like fashion to
try to uncover as much as they can about
what looks very similar to insurgency
movements they've seen overseas where
they
germinate in different parts of the
country and gain strength
and bring together an unholy alliance
frequently of religious extremists
authoritarians
fascists bigots racists nativists
and even libertarians
this is the extent that they are going
to to
try to undermine the rights and freedoms
that are guaranteed to every one of us
and it's incredibly dangerous it is so
dangerous
and and it's also uh happening on a
greater scale we've ever seen before
because as you point out
in the video that i hope every one of
our viewers will find on the internet it
isn't simply government officials
and our intel and law enforcement
agencies it's also
private businesses it's these giant tech
monopolies
what can the rest of us do to protect
ourselves to keep free speech alive
in a moment when it's being crushed all
around us
first of all keep speaking i think this
is the most important thing at a time
when
there is so much fear and threats
and and the kind of fomenting of fear
that we're seeing coming from the likes
of john brennan
take a stand we must all take a stand
and unite around these principles
in our constitution and continue to
speak freely whether it be
in person on the street corner or on
these virtual
public squares these town squares that
exist
online you know big tech is
culpable in this in that they are using
their monopolistic power to pick and
choose whose voices are heard and whose
voices
are squelched whether it's based on who
they agree with disagree with political
affiliation who you voted for
or whatever i think there are
alternative platforms i've got one on
tulsi.locals.com it's a place where
people can come and speak
freely and and have open dialogue and
conversation around different issues
based on respect and this appreciation
for our constitutional
rights and freedoms but i think most
importantly we need to urge president
biden and every member of congress how
critical it is they take a stand and
denounce the likes of john brennan and
adam schiff's actions
because if we do not and if they do not
then this country that we love and
cherish
will no longer exist i think that's
right when you ran for president
as a democrat i watched the leadership
of the democratic party try to subvert
your campaign they disliked you more
than they disliked donald trump almost
and now i think we know why because
you're defending
the basic institutions of our country i
appreciate you doing it on this show
chelsea gabbard thank you
thank you